Let's go next to our caller from the 5 7 0
area code who's calling today from 5 7 0 that,
Lou.
Yes, it is.
Hey.
What's up?
I called like a bunch of times, and this is
the first I'm going on.
So thank you, Francine.
Love it.
Yeah.
So I'm a huge burning supporter.
I donated like 60 times to him.
I'm super depressed about how to turn down
this race.
Yeah.
And.
I just I don't know.
You think that.
And what do you think really went wrong?
I you really think it would have been attract
more people to our kind of cause and the business
too abrasive kind of how we went about things?
Is that what you're thinking?
Listen, I have I've got a couple videos on
this and you can check them out.
But to sum this up, the long and short of
it is there's a couple different issues.
Number one, Bernie's policies aren't as popular
as you would think from watching his rallies
and looking at Twitter and read it.
I'm not saying they're unpopular.
They just weren't popular enough to swing
the Democratic electorate.
Number two, the Democratic electorate is not
as progressive as it sounds like you are.
And as progressive as I am.
Number three, Bernie did have language around
his campaign that didn't help.
It wasn't a benefit to keep going with the
democratic socialist thing.
He didn't gain anything by doing that.
And it only if possibly lose.
And so there's a bunch of different stuff.
The toxic people around there.
We'll have time for a postmortem for sure.
A deeper postmortem.
OK.
No, not really.
I appreciate taking my call.
All right.
Thanks so great.
Great to
hear from you.
Let me go next to oh, you know who I want
to talk to